moving on to Washington the president is
saying that he may announce new social
distancing guidelines today at a
briefing yesterday he downplayed the
needs of states hit hardest by the virus
claiming that testing is no longer an
issue and blaming medical workers for
the shortage of supplies now he's
getting pushback himself as we Jiang
reports from the White House from the
Rose Garden President Trump said
governors across the country were happy
with the help from the federal
government referencing a video
conference call with them earlier in the
day I think for the most part they were
saying thank you for doing a great job
CBS News obtained a recording of the
call and while the governors did think
the president they also raised concerns
Montana governor steve bullock warned
the president a delay in testing could
soon overwhelm hospitals in rural areas
and said his state does not have the
capability to test and at the briefing
mr. Trump praised his administration
over 1 million Americans have now been
tested more than any other country but
the u.s. is lagging in the number of
tests per capita and president Trump
lashed out when asked why you should be
saying congratulations on stead of
asking a really snarky question because
he also repeated his suggestion that
surgical masks were being stolen by
healthcare workers claiming a vendor
told him one New York Hospital ordered
10 to 20,000 masks before the virus but
now all of a sudden he's giving 300,000
and I said no matter how bad this is
could that be possibly is it going out
the backdoor New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo addressed the allegations if he
really believes that then he should just
called for an investigation
Governor Cuomo said he does not believe
any equipment is being stolen
as for ventilators president Trump said
production has ramped up so dramatically
the US will have enough to send to other
countries in Europe though he did not
provide any space
like numbers or timeline Anthony we just
thank you